das hier ist Eiweiß dass du schmeckt wie
Hühnereiweiß und auch noch genau die
gleichen Nährwerte hat unter dem
Mikroskop kann man es nicht von echtem
Hühnereiweiß unterscheiden der einzige
Unterschied es ist komplett ohne Tiere
entstanden ähnlich wie laborfleisch über
das wir ja auch schon mal ein Video
gemacht haben und das beste diese neue
Technologie funktioniert nicht nur für
Eier sondern für quasi jedes Protein
jeden anderen Inhaltsstoff der
Tierprodukte zu dem macht was sie sind
mit Käse Fleisch all das könnte bald
vegan aber trotzdem echt auf den Markt
kommen in diesem Video sprechen wir
darüber wie revolutionär das ist was das
für unsere Zukunft bedeutet und warum
Europa diese Technologie anscheinend
komplett verschläft herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen Video bei dr Watson
okay woher kommt also das Ei ohne Huhn
die Methode dahinter heißt
präzisionsfermentation es klingt
kompliziert aber Menschen nutzen
Fermentationen schon seit Jahrtausenden
das heißt einfach das bestimmte Stoffe
von Mikroben oder Enzymen in andere
umgewandelt werden Bier Käse Brot ihr
habt wahrscheinlich heute mindestens
einmal etwas fermentiertes gegessen oder
getrunken Prost in China wurden schon
von 9000 Jahren fermentierte Getränke
aus Reis Honig und Früchten Geschlecht
das ist die traditionelle Fermentation
quasi kontrolliertes verderben lassen
von Lebensmitteln so machen mich
säurebakterien Milch zu Joghurt oder
Weißkohl zu Sauerkraut Hefen machen aus
Traubensaft Weinen anfangs sind diese
Produkte zufällig entstanden Milch und
rohes Gemüse sind jetzt nicht gerade für
lange Haltbarkeit bekannt aber durch die
Fermentation entstanden neue haltbare
Lebensmittel bei der präzisions
Integration die ist jetzt neu wird aber
vom Ende ausgedacht forschende fragen
sich welches Molekül mit welchen
Eigenschaften brauche ich anschließend
wählen Sie die Mikroorganismen aus
modifizieren und füttern Sie zum
Beispiel Häfen oder Bakterien und die
verarbeiten dann das Futter zum
gewünschten Produkt bei unigo Bio aus
Finnland die Hühnereiweiß herstellen
sieht das z.B so aus das Protein
ovalbumin ist das häufigste Protein vom
Hühnerei klar um es herzustellen wird
ein Pilz gehen modifiziert No Go
aber keine Sorge das ist gar nicht
schlimm und dazu kommen wir gleich in
einem bio-reaktor wird der Pilz mit
Glukose Mineralien und Stickstoff
gefüttert und produziert das Oval bumin
nach der Fermentation wird es von Pilz
getrennt anschließend wird es zu Pulver
verarbeitet weil es sich so leicht und
günstig transportieren lässt und haltbar
ist obwohl der Pilz eigentlich das
gleiche wie das Huhn macht ist er
deutlich besser im Huhn sein
zumindest wenn es nicht darum geht
draußen auf der Wiese zu chillen oder
als chicken Wing zu überzeugen sondern
eben Eiweiß zu produzieren ein Huhn
braucht zum Beispiel
27,5 Kilo Futter für ein Kilogramm
ovalbumin der Pilz braucht nur rund
viereinhalb Kilogramm für die gleiche
Menge auch im landbedarf ist das Pilz
Eiweiß deutlich besser je nach Szenario
wurden 87 bis 89% weniger Land für die
Herstellung gebraucht und auch die
Treibhausgasemissionen sind 35 bis 55 %
geringer diese Zahlen schauen wir uns
aber gleich noch mal genauer an weil es
hier ein kleines Problemchen gibt okay
wir haben jetzt also echtes
hühnereiweißpulver das Pilze für uns
hergestellt haben das ist schon ziemlich
cool aber wäre schon mal probiert hat
vegan zu essen der weiß dass die wahre
Versuchung Käse ist und hier gibt es
wahnsinnig gute Neuigkeiten den kann man
nämlich auch durch
präzisionsvermentation herstellen das
deutsche Unternehmen vormo stellt mit
Häfen Milchproteine wie Kasein her und
will dieses Jahr den Käse daraus in
Singapur auf den Markt bringen und
impossible foods davon habt ihr
vielleicht schon gehört stellt
Fleischalternativen aus Pflanzen her die
aber genauso schmecken sollen wie das
Original den Ersatzprodukten die wir
heute in Deutschland kaufen können zum
Beispiel von Beyond meat fehlt dafür
aber noch eine entscheidende Zutat das
Molekül hem ist für den fleischigen
Geschmack verantwortlich und genau das
lässt impossible foods von modifizierten
Häfen produzieren
theoretisch kann man so alle möglichen
Moleküle herstellen und genau die
gesuchten Eigenschaften in Endprodukte
bringen hä sorgt für den
Fleischgeschmack oh weil bumin für
lockeren Eischnee Milchproteine für
käsefärben den Bauplan für das
gewünschte Produkt bekommen die
Mikroorganismen durchgehen Modifikation
das ist aber nicht das gleiche wie z.B
bei GMO heißt die Mikroorganismen sind
im Endprodukt nicht enthalten sondern
werden nur für die Produktion genutzt
das klingt ja alles fast so gut um wahr
zu sein Tierprodukte ohne Tierhaltung
große Potenziale für die Umwelt ohne
Pestizide und landbedarf aber wie groß
ist das umweltpotential denn tatsächlich
und genau da kommen wir zu einem Problem
wir konnten keine unabhängige Studie
finden die die Umweltvorteile von
präzisionsfermentation prüft ja es
stimmt das Mikroorganismen auf ein
Endprodukt bezogen zum Beispiel
Milchprotein weniger Energie
verschwenden als es Tiere tun außerdem
ist es natürlich weniger aufwendig wenn
nur die Bausteine hergestellt werden die
für besondere Eigenschaften
verantwortlich sind und nicht das
komplette Produkt aber bisher gibt es
außer von den Firmen selbst keine
Angaben dazu wie groß diese Zahlen
tatsächlich sind oder irgendwann mal
sein könnten bisher haben sich
Universitäten und andere unabhängige
Einrichtungen damit noch nicht
ausführlich auseinandergesetzt und das
liegt wahrscheinlich einfach daran dass
wir hier gerade über die cutting edge
das Fortschritts im Ernährungsbereich
sprechen
das ganze Markt entsteht gerade erst die
Zahlen der Unternehmen sind natürlich
nicht aus der Luft gegriffen trotzdem
nicht alle Unternehmen haben schon große
Produktionsstätten so ein Unternehmen
fängt im Labor an baut dann eine kleine
Pilotanlage und erst dann wird alles auf
Anlagen geskeilt die für die
Massenproduktion ausgelegt sind das
heißt dass zumindest einige Unternehmen
heute eigentlich nur schätzen können wie
groß die Effekte für verschiedene
Umweltaspekte aussehen werden in der
Analyse von unego Bayo gibt es aber auch
große Unterschiede je nachdem wo die
Pilze das Eiweiß produzieren das liegt
z.B daran dass die bio-reaktoren mit
Strom auf Temperatur gehalten werden
müssen und verschiedene Länder haben
eben unterschiedlich viel erneuerbare in
ihrem Strom Mix das bedeutet aber auch
das ist noch Luft nach oben gibt wenn
dort mehr erneuerbare eingesetzt werden
zum Beispiel in der Zukunft wenn wir nur
noch erneuerbare Energien in unserem
stromex haben dann könnte es fast gar
keinen CO2 Fußabdruck mehr haben und man
kann auch noch mehr optimieren z.B wenn
der Pilz der das herstellt auch noch
genutzt wird Christ Langowski von ohne
wobeio hat uns erklärt dass man daraus
zum Beispiel eine lederalternative
herstellen kann oder man füttert den
Pilz mit licknocellulose aus Holz oder
Stroh was die Umweltauswirkungen weiter
minimieren könnte
Käse Ei oder hem aus präzisions
Fermentation werden also aller
Wahrscheinlichkeit nach deutlich besser
für die Umwelt sein als ihre tierischen
Gegenstücke wie groß die Effekte genau
sind das ist von sehr vielen Faktoren
abhängig was aber auf jeden Fall gut ist
es leiden keine Tiere und wir brauchen
ohne Tierhaltung weniger Antibiotika und
Pestizide wir hätten ja für dieses Video
hier richtig gerne mal Pilz Eiweiß oder
häfenkäse probiert und immerhin gibt es
in den USA die Israel und den Singapur
schon Produkte aus präzisions
Fermentation zu kaufen aber leider sieht
das in Deutschland noch anders aus woran
liegt das tatsächlich an der Bürokratie
wer hätte das gedacht genauer gesagt an
der novel food Verordnung der EU klar
neue Lebensmittel sollten ausgiebig
geprüft werden auf jeden Fall aber das
immer noch ziemlich absurd werden ein
Unternehmen musste seinen veganen
Ei-Ersatz prüfen lassen weil exotische
Mungbohnen enthalten sind die seit
Ewigkeiten in Asien gegessen werden
diese Prüfung kann durch die
ineffiziente Bürokratie hier gut und
gerne mal mehrere Jahre dauern
kritisieren die Start-ups in Singapur
geht das deutlich schneller obwohl die
Kriterien genauso streng sein sagen
Institute aus der Branche und impossible
food wartet zum Beispiel schon seit 2019
auf die EU-Zulassung obwohl es den
Hamburger in Neuseeland Links zu kaufen
gibt
[Musik]
aber wenn es mal soweit ist werden wir
dann in ein paar Jahren ganz normal
Cheeseburger mit fermentiertem ham und
tierfreiem Käse essen ehrlich gesagt ich
kann mir schon vorstellen dass
präzisions Fermentation da ein riesiges
Potenzial hat die Umweltauswirkungen der
Tierhaltung sind gigantisch die food and
every culture Organisation der UN
schätzt die Emissionen auf 7,1
Gigatonnen CO2 äquivalente jährlich das
sind 14,5% der gesamte Emissionen und
einfach mal so viel wie die gesamten
weltweiten transportemissionen im Jahr
2020 trotzdem ist eine große Gruppe an
Menschen nicht bereit auf Tierprodukte
zu verzichten wenn die versteht das
Produkte aus präzisions Fermentation
genau die Eigenschaften haben die sie an
Tierprodukten liebt dann könnte das eine
Menge auslösen zumindest geben in
Umfragen zwischen 30 und 70% der
Befragten an dass sie Käse aus
präzisions Fermentation kaufen würden
probieren würden ihn je nach Umfrage
sogar knapp 80% ihr auch schreibt mir
das gerne mal unten in die Kommentare
ich gehöre auf jeden Fall dazu und hoffe
darauf dass ich bald in meine erste
tierfreie Käse Pizza beißen kann darum
hoffe ich dass das mit der Zulassung
schnell klappt ich finde es immer wieder
krass zu sehen und super faszinierend
was ist gerade alles für Innovationen
gibt woran überall geforscht wird und
wie schnell die Menschheit
voranschreitet und neue Dinge erfindet
und ich glaube unter euch sind einige
denen das genauso geht wenn ihr Ideen
für Innovationen habt dann schreibt euch
mal den 19 oktober in den Kalender da
organisiert proendes go Bio initial eine
Veranstaltung für junge
Nachwuchswissenschaftlerinnen aus den
Hochschulen in NRW da könnt ihr euch
nämlich über Fördermöglichkeiten im Life
science-bereich informieren also zum
Beispiel in den Bereichen Gesundheit
Medizintechnik oder der Wirkstoffsuche
ihr könnt hier neue Projektideen
entwickeln oder wenn ihr schon eine Idee
habt diese weiterentwickeln ihr lernt
wie man den perfekten Antrag stellt und
mit etwas Glück gibt es sogar Geld für
eure innovative okay denn es sind auch
einige namhafte Institutionen vor Ort
und ich bin auch da und werde in einer
Keynote über spannende
Zukunftstechnologien berichten
vielleicht sehen wir uns also da mit
go-bio Initialen will das
Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung Entwicklungen mit erkennbarem
Innovationspotenzial fördern und sie
auch schon früh auf eine spätere
Kommerzialisierung ausrichten bis Anfang
Oktober könnt ihr euch noch anmelden und
dann sehen wir uns in Essen ein Link mit
weiteren Infos und wie ihr euch anmelden
könnt findet ihr unten in der
Videobeschreibung wie immer vielen Dank
fürs zuschauen und bleibt neugierig euer
Cedric tiefen machen aus Tauben Saft
Wein taubensaft